c'est une première à versaill la petite
Thérèse a pu être vénérée à la
cathédrale Saint-Louis par
l'intermédiaire de ses reliques de
sainte Thérèse sainte Thérèse était une
jeune normande de la fin du 19e siècle
elle est née en 1873 elle est morte en
1897 et c'était elle a consacré une
grande partie de sa vie à à une vie dans
la prière au Carmel de Lisieux un
message vraiment de confiance dans
l'amour du Seigneur qu'elle cherchait à
vivre d'une manière très simple et très
ordinaire c'est aussi à mon avis pour
cela que elle rejoint beaucoup de
personnes c'est que elle a une vie très
très ordinaire et elle parle à beaucoup
de gens et d'ailleurs ce qui est
frappant c'est que de voir dans la
cathédrale beaucoup de gens viennent
vénérer sainte- Thérèse la carmélite a
connu une conversion lors d'une nuit de
Noël c'est aussi les 150 ans de sa
naissance une raison de plus pour la
paroisse versaillaise de la célébrer TS
de veiller de prière compte pour enfants
mess ou encore conférence un programme
complet pour lequel les fidèles ont fait
le
déplacement
c'était une occasion de faire un mini
pèlerinage puisque nous surmontons une
difficulté de la vie donc voilà ça nous
a permis d'avoir un moment de
recueillement
et de garder confiance et amour comme
sainte Thérèse j'aime bien cette petite
sainte et puis voilà quoi voilà je
compte sur elle pour que pour qu'elle
nous protège ma famille toute ma famille
elle est tré très jeune et que et que
c'est la sainte la plus aimée dans le
monde entier je pense c'est un lieu d'
pour moi donc c'était plutôt sympa les
reliques de sainte Thérèse ont
aujourd'hui quitté la cité royale la
carmélite poursuit son voyage initié en